well there's some flexibility built into
the rules to allow broadcasters to be
as creative positively creative about
how you make programs impartial now
could that be done within the program
somehow by having some sort of content
that would reflect mr cameron's view
would you do it outside the program but
in alliance with the main program that i
think is a challenge to the broadcasters
if the prime minister is not going to
turn up how is his voice going to be
heard either in the program or around
the program but i mean you know the hard
choice is currently as planned seven
days before polling very sensitive time
we could have an hour an hour and a half
of uh ed miliband broadcasting with an
empty chair could that ever happen do
you think though the question is what
would that look like as a program it
would probably look like a pretty normal
program in which a politician meets an
audience i mean we've been making
programs like that for 20 30 years i
think the intriguing thing is supposing
that happened now the next morning david
cameron brings up and says when do i get
my go at that do they then say oh no you
missed your chance you should have been
here last night we won't do a program
like that with you so there's a lot more
games to be played i think a lot more
cards to be played by number 10 people
are kind of thinking this is the moment
of truth and he has to decide is he
going to turn up or not but i'd be
surprised if they haven't got a few more
a few more plan b's up their sleeve now
it matters to us as television news
professionals we think this is what
television should be doing does it
matter to the wider public do you think
well because we've had now a debate or
serious debates last time which so
captured the public mood and
particularly young people remember how
young people were engaged in a way
they've never been before so to actually
say to them actually we're not going to
you might expect you're going to get it
this time around but you're not because
one party leader chooses it's not in his
interest to do it you're taking you're
taking a chance aren't you with with the
pub what the public will make of that
clearly the prime minister's advisors
think that's a chance worth taking um i
just think that actually you can't put
this issue to bed because during the
campaign all the time there'll be
constant reminders that the prime
minister hasn't turned up three times if
you like he hasn't turned up so there's
not as though you can kind of bottle
this and then say it's all over it won't
be over until virtually a few days
before the election now of course danny
three say well yes he will do a debate
that's what our final offer was about
yeah and if i was them i'd be trying to
create some vehicle of some kind with
somebody either one of the broadcasters
or more likely somebody who's not one of
the broadcasters that allowed me to say
i did a debate whether it's before the
campaign or after the campaign i think
that's the that's the box that the prime
minister needs to take but he may be
able to create some other place some
other time not one necessarily suits the
broadcasters that allows him to to do
that i mean the odd thing is is that the
2015 debates to a certain extent may
have suffered from you know second novel
or second album syndrome as much as
people a bit bored by them but this is
actually whipping up the interest of
them again well so it certainly is in
the in the tv newsrooms of london
whether the average viewers and
listeners are connecting with it quite
the same way i don't know but they're
certainly expecting it to happen and if
it doesn't happen i suspect a lot of
people are going to be disappointed yeah
so what does your gut tell you my gut
tells me there's there's a wild card or
two yet to be thrown in before this this
this story finishes but do you think
a debate or debate of some kind
involving david cameron and other
leaders will take place i think
something will happen that will allow
david cameron to say i had a debate now
whether that resembles what you might
think of he passed from miranda
something like that he just needs to be
seen to turn up somewhere at some date
what about the risk for the broadcasters
in pushing it in the way they have
well you know people said to me you know
what about the bbc charter renewal
that's coming up my experience is in
that sometimes when broadcasters take on
politicians actually the public sides
with the broadcasters and that just
might happen this occasion